Cousin, bro. You're tripping like crazy, I was just flirting
with her, but I touch no one in the ass, bro. That's crazy, bro.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'll show you I'll show you what
I Can I show you what I did? No, hell no. Now, Darius has two
best friends that are pests. Bro, shout out to the blonde girls.
They deserve some love.
Hey, they want to see you dance. Like they want to They want
to see you dance, girl. Like woo!
Hey, I heard uh I white girls can't
I don't know.
Can't twerk? I don't know. Want to see it. I don't want to show
you. You have A LITTLE BIT OF SPACE HERE. OKAY, OKAY. Let's see
it. Let's see it. Let's do it.
Yo, baby. Chris, Chris, Chris and them. Chris and
Man, as soon as I talk to some some girl, a guy comes out of
nowhere, bro. White knights. You got a bunch of white knights
out here, bro. White knights.
What happened?
What? He telling you you touching on these females. No, I'm just
saying hi. No. You got to slide, bro. Play it back, but you got
to go. I haven't even bothered anyone.
okay, I'm going.
All right.
Hey, bro, I got to go.
Okay. I got pressed for the 100th time. You know how we get out
here, you know what I'm saying, bro? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hell yeah,
son. Hell yeah, son. Yeah,
Always getting pressed out here, man. This cop thing, dog.
I was just trying to mack on y'all.
Let's go. Hey, come on, homie. Let's go.
You just drunk. You done. Come on. Stop talking to someone, bro.
You're just talking to girls.
I was just talking to the Oh, no, what's up, bro? I'm driven
now.
Cousin, bro, you tripping like crazy, I was just flirting with
her, but I Nah, bro, you don't touch no one in the ass. That's
crazy, bro. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'll show you I'll show
you what I Can I show you what I did? Nah, hell no. I'm just
letting you know what what I I'm just letting you know what what
she I don't know. No, no, wait, wait, hold on, bro. Hold on.
No, no, no. No, I ain't talking about none of that stuff, man.
Get your cousin out. wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, Yo, shut the bro. Listen, man. Okay, I'll listen. just
know girl, bro. That's a female. Right, he told me that he wants
She deserves to be punished and [__] bro. I seen
this guy would have slapped the dog out you. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, That's not cool, shlon. That [__]
is not cool, bro. You a grown ass man to a woman, bro. Bro, how
do you how do you flirt with I don't touch them by the ass. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I went up
to her and That's lame. Listen to me. You ain't going to listen
to me. I ain't going to
Whatever, bro. Whatever, bro. Just get back in there.
I'm going to [__] Call a girl.
Call a girl. All right.
You can either go down that way or All
Hey, y'all ladies looking beautiful
What's What's y'all plan?
Y'all want to go to another bar or what's up? Are y'all from
Dallas?
I'm from Houston. I'm from Houston, baby.
I was thinking looking good. My bad.
You don't want to talk to me? All right. All right.
He got to look for me, bro. I I I kind of like came with you
here, Go on, dog. I was just trying to flirt,
I really hope I really hope you didn't do that, bro. Okay, I'm
I'll admit that I did do it, but like I was drunk.
I was drunk, dog. Man, whatever, dog. I was just trying to provide
some wrist content, dog. Stop saying Dude, you don't know that.
That's what I was trying to do, dog, on the real. You touched
her ass. Okay, cuz that's what I'll be doing sometimes but like
cuz girls like that [__] dog.
All right, okay. So, you going to let me look bad, okay? You
going to make me look bad? No, you're looking bad yourself, bro.
You're saying you're That's bad, too. You're like doubling down,
bro. I meant it. I didn't do it. Okay, then just apologize. Yeah,
I've been I've been saying I'm sorry for the last couple hours.
How did you touch her ass? Rico Gotti has to be exiled forever
for his transgression.
You want to see this? Do you see Do you see how bad he is? All
right. He got me hard as [__]
From the girl you love the most, it's like I felt like This guy
is so casual getting a boner tonight. And you just know it wasn't
his. Rico Gotti has to be exiled forever for his transgression.
Where is all the Madonna's asking for a crazy like we
And explain what happens. Yeah, but that's the illest that ever
happened in my life. I've never
That's the Keep being strong. Keep streaming.
Thank you for the follow. Stay healthy. You know what I'm saying?
I go to the gym. Get a fad. Yeah, I know. Where Where are you
guys going? To hit this to Zushcard to get her What's up? You
you say you're at
Do you Do you I got I got No, I would not need a cigarette.
You want one, too? I got plenty. Oh, what type?
Wait, did he go?
Wait, you want me to go with you
What are you waiting for? She wants a tripod.
No, I'm going to go.
because I was 10 steps ahead All right, ready? Okay, I have to
go. I'll probably go
Right here. I wish I could go to Austin. I'm going with Rico
also Adrian.
This way.
everyone's getting their like gradual spot. The rapture tree
is going up to a 10. Wait, did he get his keys?
Bro, are you serious? Don't go back in there. Rico Rico Rico
Rico. Don't go press your protector. Bro, no. I just I'm just
trying to get this [__] to calm down, bro. Like bro,
this is so much Okay.
Hey, can you can I have the key can I have the key? I'm just
going to take your keys, okay? I got you. Okay, we're good. Okay,
let's go. Are you do you want to stay over there or are they
doing content? You're going the wrong way. Okay, is it that way?
Hey, Rico here. Oh my god. Bro, that's There's so much going
on. Mark the next unit, no?
Bro, your truck is Anyway, you don't need him.
Yeah, it's it's big as it's big as too. And there's a lot of
Dude, this is way more people than Austin.
Yeah. Did you actually fondle
It was an accident. What happened?
They said I groped her butt like I wasn't trying to grope her
I was just drawing. I was trying to flirt with her I didn't know
she was taken. I didn't know she was taken, Chad. But how did
you Okay, well how did you touch her, bro? You know what I'm
saying? You know, when you drunk a little bit you'll be feeling
up on them girls, you know what I'm saying? You know how we do.
Uh no, I don't really. I don't No, I don't really do that, Rico.
It was an accident. I had 100 viewers at one point though.
Are you are you kidding me right now? I had 150 at one point.
Dude, you know the term like
So, you did grab her up then, Rico?
Rico touched her. I didn't mack on no women out here, dog. Wait,
did you actually Did I'm sorry. Did you actually grope her, bro?
I would eat that vomit. It was an accident. Okay, so you did
grope her, bro. What the [__] I did not grope her,
bro. That's crazy, bro.
You're with me, you're guilty by association, bro. I'll put it
on everything. Rico, I can't be associated with you, bro. That's
crazy. That's bad, bro. Mark throwing up? No. No, I wouldn't
do something along like that. Hey. Hey, I'm good. I'll provide
the content tonight, bro. Like grope? Dude, you got to be tripping,
bro. You know, that's what made me sick. Yeah, I can only do
a little bit. Dude, though, Rico and Dallas, you belong here.
Maybe this is your spot.
Yeah, that is. Is your car here?
No, his car is secure. We're going to my car. Oh, you're going
to find his? Okay. It's over here? All right, where's Nate? Where's
Did Did Did Pickle just leave? Get that out of here. No, he went
to his house.
Hey, I'm sick of you, bro. What the [__] they saying,
bro? They macking on me, They're saying you're crazy, bro. Bro,
I was trying to provide content. The whole night I was trying
to provide No, that's not what they were saying you were doing,
bro. Bro. God brought Rico into your life. I feel it in my nuts.
They mack those. Rico groping random women isn't providing content.
That's just
You're weird. You are weird. Why am I weird? You're weird. I
wonder why. If you actually grope somebody, that's crazy, bro.
not grope nobody, dog. You just literally like said you did,
and then you said, "I got 100 views."
If it were me, you would say, "Don't lie, Darious." Okay, but
you like didn't deny it. I believe Rico is from Gaming God. No,
you can come. You can come, bro. You're good. She's just mad
at you, bro. She doesn't want to talk to you. It's It's okay.
No, you can't apologize, bro. Leave her alone. I already said
I'm sorry to her, bro. Okay, well, that's not going to fix it,
She's not She didn't hug you, bro. Providing content is just
being weird. That's not her cousin, bro. Well, that's what he
said it was. It's just trolling, bro. I didn't know her, bro.
So, what were you I really just don't I haven't seen the clip
yet, but I hope you did not touch anybody, bro. No, it's a it's
a it's a really bad look for me, bro. Cuz I I I got I came with
you here, bro.
I really hope you I really hope you didn't do that, bro.
I was drunk, dog.
I was just trying to provide some wrist Stop. Dude, you don't
know that at all.
They said that they're saying you touched her ass. Okay, cuz
that's what I'd be doing sometimes, but like cuz girls like that.
No, you're looking bad yourself, bro. You're saying you're saying
that's bad, too. You're like doubling down, bro.
Okay, then it's just apologize. Yeah, you No, you were drunk.
I'm just saying I'm sorry. How did How did you touch her ass?
I don't know. Look, I went up to her. I was like, "Damn, you
look adorable." But like I I put my hand around her waist. You
but no, you did not.
I did it, bro. Why would you Dude, what the
Okay, so some girls like if I'm wrong, like they don't put your
hand away, that means they like you. So, I do that, bro. Bro,
bro, no. That's not how that works, all right, kid. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Oh, they're they're making me mad at me like they
got And how many people on there? Like 1,300. Damn. Hey, follow
me at FBG.
You only use your nuts for what?
People are saying you did, my bro.
Oh, yeah, I got some bling here. Have you had this place though?
This place is actually good. They knew I was going to Dallas.
They do a thing. Well, there's like a bunch These are like a
This is a chain. They put like a bunch of They put dumplings
in like these little kiosk things for you that you can order.
And they're like they're mid. But it's cool though. And they're
expensive as like $7 a dumpling. Darius, ditch that
bro. He groped someone at Did you actually I'm going to see I'm
I'm going to Rico, they're saying they're saying you groped someone's
ass,
Chat, let us get our [__] first. Clark, did I grope
You don't ask me. I got kicked out too, so I don't know why you're
too many questions. I got kicked out too. But I didn't grope
nobody. If you actually grope someone, that's crazy cuz you said
you couldn't go back to the bar afterwards. Well, she couldn't
either. This is the DIRM. But not Okay, she got like yelled at
or whatever by some person, so that's why.
By who? Well, you're pretty. I You want to I'm going to tell
you what no one else Look at it in front of running cameras.
I put myself out there. That's dude. I was because I put myself
out there. And I tried to Rico, you got to take Rico, you got
to take Rico, that's why I'm a Rico, that's why I'm a creep because
I actually try to provide that other streamers which is like
in their heads in their heads. They can't talk they can't flirt
with no girls. They can't flirt with no girls because they're
You know what I'm saying? Rico, they're not [__]
with that. Bro, I really provide that real [__] Rico,
I'm literally telling you you're a [__] creep and
the only reason I'm am I a creep though? Why am I a creep? Well,
putting your hands on somebody
You said you put it around her waist, you said you PUT YOUR HAND
AROUND her waist. Did you not? You said that you just told me
that. You just told me you put your hand around her waist. So,
you're saying you wouldn't do that? No, I would not. Never, dog.
You're not drug like me. I still I still wouldn't put my hand
around her waist. What? Clark touched my PP. Watch the clip.
I'll watch it later. Clark, why you instigating this? Man, no,
no, face this [__] forward, dog. You sleep off your
little time. on in this chat, bro? What the [__]
y'all saying? I ain't instigated nothing out here, dog. I didn't
touch nobody, dog. Who did I touch? Say the name. Say the name
in the chat. Who did I touch, man?
Who the [__] did I A grope game? I didn't touch nobody,
dog. Okay, well, if they prove that you did touch somebody, then
that's really what did I touch? Chat, Alexis is what they're
saying. even know who the [__] that chick is. You
know exactly who Alexis is cuz I saw you talk
Here we go. Here we go now. Here we go. Alexis and Maddie. Are
you getting You're getting Are you getting Do you want him in
the live? We got people in the live for you, bro. Here we go,
dog. Are you serious? I did not touch I did not touch that girl,
I'm going to round six, bro. Hey, what Are you trolling? Okay.
Let me see the clip then. Send the [__] clip. Pull
up the clip right now, dog. I didn't touch nobody. Hey, someone
post a clip. Post the [__] clip, chat. Post the clip.
Did I touch somebody? I'm always getting pressed, bro, when I'm
drunk, dog. Well, if you If you're touching people when you're
drunk, then you should not get drunk, bro, bro. Man, I've been
drinking all morning, bro. I'm dead. You touched Maddie. It's
literally on camera. Everyone is sending clips. Grope gang, there
ain't no Grope gang. Pull up the clip, Darius. Let me look at
the clip. Rico only touched her one time, y'all.
Darius, Rico also groped Maddie. Oh, bro, you're just spreading
rumors. Spreading rumors. Why is he denying it like he didn't
confirm it five times? Is he slow in the head? Call me my baby
boy. There's a second clip where he tried to grab Maddie and
Prawn is literally filming him. Do it Prawn was encouraging Maddie?
No, he was not. What? What are they saying? There are two clips
with two different Alexis and Maddie. Both clips are being posted.
He just admitted to it two minutes ago. What are they saying
to me? How was I creepy to Maddie? I was just saying she looked
like a doll. What's wrong with saying that? That's the clip.
This guy is a I'm sending it to the office, all right. Damn,
bro. I'm a Prawn is filming both gropes that we Sam who? Prank
was trying to save the girl. He was some kind of predator.
Did you say Sam? I marked down bad. You sure you don't prefer
somebody like Loaves or Action? I prefer like Loaves or Action.
Nah, she like Dude, I cannot believe you like Did you actually
touch someone bro? Like he just Ah, let me see it. I probably
did dog. On the real I did. Okay, did you do it to Maddie as
well?
If you do it to Maddie that's like unexcusable. I can literally
can't I'm sorry. I No, Alexis is bad but like You Chad, why are
you telling them this? Dog. I was just trying to flirt. I was
trying to contact you guys. You're going to put me on the spot
light.
I'm the only one providing content out here bro. Y'all put me
on the spot Maddie dodged it. Oh, bro. You're getting like flat
I'm not even joking. People are on your ass I don't even remember
it at this point. Yes dog. Dude, you got to not drink then right
Darius Prank is the mastermind behind the groaks. Dog, did Prank
actually encourage it? No, he did not. He didn't actually do
It's on my dude, I can't claim you bro. You're not my man.
Dog, it was bad when Prank scared the Korean girl off the air.
Dog, especially after earlier bro. I My reputation's already
hurt. I thought you were just going to be chill. You said you
were going to be Well, I didn't know you were going to start
touching people inappropriately
I never did that. Well, I mean like except for like Well, I was
going to defend you dog. Except for that one guy. You got jumped
by like five five Dude, I thought I was there. Alexis told you
to put your hands behind your back. Oh, if I was there I would
have defended you dog. I would have defended you dog.
Well, if you were I would not have defended you with that's what
happened. And people are saying that's what happened. I can't
defend you bro. I can't just be like oh, he's drunk and And he's
touching on girls and You got jumped by like five people. Okay,
come in. Uh, if I'm doing some weird [__] no, don't
defend me. Keep me accountable. Oh, yeah, you were doing some
weird Darius, take a second and go look at the clips they're
posting. He's confirmed on All right. Yeah. Someone could say
on top and step in the middle and Darius, just say that you simply
would not have groped women. All right, thank you. Thank you.
And my ice pack.
Thank you so much. It's our boys. Were you going to take it to
your car? Dude, you can Two clips of him groping women in the
same night. The child molester.
You just have to, bro. I was just trying to provide content.
Why is Prawn filming both gropes? Prawn waits for Rico to grope
them, then swoops in to rescue them. He is a Oh my gosh, I hate
you guys. What the Dude, if you did that dude, if you actually
touched her butt At this point, you got to fight Rico to prove
you weren't groping her. Who's Prawn, man? I already got pressed
by 100 that's her Chubby cheese mouse looking [__]
Trying to provide content by groping So you definitely a gropist.
It's like How am I groping? If you grabbed her ass I didn't touch
no one. You're Well, here's the thing. I'm going to look at the
clip now. You You were acting mad weird around Kick Rico out
of your life. He's toxic. mad weird around Oil Around who?
You were with the Oil boys? Cut ties and go with Merc. What's
wrong with them? Okay, well Punishment stream for Rico when back
in Rico, it's good that you barely have a streaming career with
your three viewers that you lost over this. No more compliments,
Rico is anti-clout. That's not
Darius, both clips with the audio. I don't think that's what
happened, bro. Handing out compliments left and right, left and
right compliments. All right, so all right, so I'm going to You
are disgusting. If you're actually flipping trash, I'm out here
eating cat. I'm out here eating The whole night handing out compliments.
There's no way that you have to pull up the clips. Just watch
them, then see what you think. It's weird prawn is there two
chilling.
Shut the [__] up, Merc. You smell like and look like
green.
Rico really tried saying it was fine for him to grope two women
because he was drunk. You might need to fight him or make him
walk.
If I ever meet you, Rico, outside.
Darius, behold the IRL house. Remember when Rico first met Abby?
He said,
Hold on. Hold on.
How do I go on? Show me these [__] Show me. What
happened? What happened? What happened? I still don't see it.
I am Merc. Where's the prawn angle? You smell like [__]
Where's the prawn angle?
Look at that. I'm flirting with her, though. Flirting with her.
Another clip of him groping I didn't know she had a house. Anna
has just been on Earth gets the worst one yet. And
Merc, you're the prettiest crackhead in
He told you to put your hands behind your back, bro.
Why wouldn't you like put your arm around her shoulder or something?
You're out flirting with her, bro. You haven't said What the
[__] is this video? Dude, what are you looking at?
Kick this
He's going to try to grope more. Mr. President, groping clip
Show Let me see the video. Let me see the video. Where did Where
did I touch her? Where did I touch her? I don't see me I don't
see myself touching her, dog. Where? Where the [__]
is the touch?
Nothing. I didn't touch that. I did I did not touch that girl,
dog. She literally said you tried to touch my I did not touch
you, bro. Okay, well You don't see it on the clip cuz it didn't
ever happen. People are saying you have There's another clip.
Let's look at the other
Bro, nobody wants to be ripped by you. They want to be
I understand that. That's why I got kicked out of the car. Watch
the other clips. You did it Wait, what the Baby, where did I
touch her? Oh, bro, you're weird as [__] bro. Weird,
bro.
What the
That's number two. That's Maddie. How did she stop Wait, that's
Maddie, right? I think so. They all look the same.
That's why I got in trouble. You're a creep. Like, these people
feel so uncomfortable around you, and we all see it. But, they're
supposed to take it because it's just what it Darius, come get
your mans. How about you I'm not touching you. I'm not touching
you. I'm not even talking to them, but you're touching them.
Don't touch them when You are not
Stop TALKING TO WOMEN.
AND LOOK AT THAT, PRANA ENCOURAGING THE WHOLE SITUATION. Prana
is encouraging. Dude, what? Darius, what I'm sorry. I'm sorry,
bro. Bro, bro. That is three times in a row you went for the
ass. That is three I see nothing? Where? Dude, are you trolling?
There I see nothing. You actually are Not I'm not even
That's serial like gropish, bro. Like, that ain't even funny.
There's nobody.
Don't try to cancel me before I can get
You went for it the first time. You went for it the I'm sorry.
You went for You went for it Right here, dude. You go for it
the You got What? Are you trolling? You tried to grab it real
quick like a weirdo, which is weird as You're not even streaming,
by the way.
And look, now she's like, "Okay."
And then, after she's like, "Okay, you're cool." Then you go
for it again. I don't see nothing. Sorry. I don't see nothing
there at all.
Darius, I will not respect you if you don't kick him out right
now.
All right. Here we go. I don't want to fight nobody. Rico, we
got to you got to go. Rico, Rico, it is actually on site
Who's on site? On site Rico, Rico. Hey, I'll press charges for
you. I'll talk about this until then.
Dog, but you know you want to be over here just calling out you
know when I
Nah, bro. All right, Rico.
You want to pull over the curb real quick and just like
Yeah, let's let's kick him out. I think you got to Bro, you got
to like
Man, like dude, it's like I look like I'm hanging out with you,
bro. Like I already have a Listen, dog. I get it, bro, but like
you got to you got to go, man. Whatever, dog. Whatever, dog.
Can can you Can Can we Can we like stay for a second? We got
to get Rico. Rico, if I see you Can Can we unlock the car and
get Rico? you're trapped so well your face might actually start
looking better.
Chat, you need to realize THAT I AM TWO STEPS ahead of everyone
else. The reason why we're being mom until I get my [__]
They got your mans on assault charges. They're actually going
to press you for assault charges.
Rico, what's the problem? What is going on, Rico? I Alexis, Hannah,
and Maddie. Rico's car in the Dallas and now they're He definitely
did touch them. Did not touch them, no. You three are radioactive
right now. Did not You can just do whatever you want.
[__] I did not touch them hoes, bro. All right, Rico.
Time to walk the plank, [__] hey.
I'm the whole reason we were even here. Without me, Darius Can
you man up for once in your life and you needed to Darius and
Rico both took LS tonight. I have I have I have to I I cannot
consider your sign your behavior. I did not touch nobody, dog.
you to you to reflect actions. What do you want me to say sorry?
Can't believe you done this. I already said sorry to Hondro.
What do you You want me to say sorry to the Well, you need to
stop defending
You say you're sorry to Hondro. You actually need to apologize
to Hondro and stop defending yourself, Rico.
I'm sorry. It's okay. I understand. I'll bow down No, you don't
And that's not even an apology, bro.
That's not a That's all I was trying to do the whole Oh, I can
get my Can I get my guitar out of there? Yeah, that's what I
was I got completely about the guitar. The prawn POV drop check
chat. Dude, there's another POV. Apologize to women little bro.
Uh I left my thing in his trunk. And you also got your best your
gay It's in the
We have to see when Dre is leaving tomorrow for leaving the tree.
Well, that's a wrap on the streaming
No, you're good. You just need like You need to like
You need to like process what your actions, bro bro.
But you already said you're sorry. Rico, you said you're sorry,
right? Guys, what if I just play guitar instead of fighting?
Rico, get the [__] out of here. No one wants you
here. Um don't drive though. Do not drive. I At the end of the
day, don't drive. Fourth clip. Bro, there's a fourth
No, he's not driving. He should not be. I don't want him to like
die. I don't know what he's doing. I I have to figure it out.
Let me figure it out. He gave you a free ride Go drive.
I'm trying to figure out what's going on right now. victim. This
man needs to be brutalized. Well, I'm not I don't I'm not staying
at the hotel. Are you done Is your night I didn't bring it. I
knew I was going to bring it. Fourth clip is the prawn POV of
the Maddie situation. Why are we ignoring prawn filming every
grope? He is the mastermind.
Rico, that's Dude, he has like no brain, dude. It's Just sleep
it off, buddy. You'll be Yeah, sleep it off. There is gift luck
here if you brutalize him for groping, I will gift you sums.
You're not going to drive, right? I don't want you to do anything
reckless. what I'm doing right now. I'm just I think you just
need to like take a moment to reflect. You want to leave me and
I don't want to leave you, bro. I don't want to leave you, but
that's that's crazy. That's What you did was diabolical, bro.
What What else do you want me to But you were defending it, bro.
If you just would have left it at that, I'd be to Hondro. Who
else do I have to say sorry to? The chat? That's not the point,
bro. Hold up. Why did you bring your guitar on the road? Did
you really think that would work on Voldemort?
Wait, do you Dude, I feel so bad. Do you Wait, do you actually
not get it? Like try to Oh, here. Try to apologize to chat real
quick while I take a I'm going to take a piss. Sorry that I Maybe
they'll Maybe they'll accept your Oh, sorry. Chat, I'm sorry
that I groped on Alexis. I was just trying to make some rizz
temp for my chat, man. That's All I was trying to do, I promise,
bro. I didn't want to get pressed by Hondro and everybody at
the bar. I got kicked out of the bar because I ended up doing
some I ended up flirting with Hannah and and Hannah and Kimmie.
I'm sorry. I really like white
Can't blame me, bro. Like I like white girls, bro. Come on, dog.
Like and I Maybe I did touch somebody.
Okay, I touched somebody, but I'm sorry, okay? I'm sorry that
I touched somebody,
I've been drinking all night. We will forgive you if you say
Prawn forced you to grope them. We know you're too dumb to mastermind
so many gropes. I don't know where the [__] that
to the victims he brutalized.
I'm not creepy. You don't you think touching women without knowing
them is rizz, you pervert? Bro, I did not mean to touch that
girl, It does not matter. You are weird. Why do you think that
is okay? 1, 2, women. Okay, cancel, but don't go don't drive
home, okay? Racist white girls are not into you, little guy.
Well, I mean like do you want us to drop you off somewhere? If
alcohol makes you
Maybe don't drink. I don't know. The phone call is To be honest,
what grade did you drop out of middle texting ABZ trying to get
me banned.
There's no way in hell, bro. all of them. Banned? Who? Darius
not taking this seriously is so The core room Never never ever
never texting him clips. She was texting him
Trying to get me banned. She tried to take my livelihood over
that. that Rico groped three girls. I gro- I did not grope no
girls, dog. Bro, she knows I was just trolling at the start,
bro. Why are we Why are we tweaking, dude? Dude, she has to be
so mad that I'm being banned after that. groper, and you're still
tripping over your ex. You're going to lose your case, IP. I'm
We told you this. like, bro. Like what a Like what a You chased
your ex down and started fights because you're jealous. Yeah,
I 100% did that. No, I'd not. I was going to go hang out, and
then Darius is okay with Rico. Bro, I told her if she attacked
me, I should be punching first. I mean, he did. I mean, to be
fair, I got in his face, but like
Rico, can you stop saying you didn't grope anyone? It's on cam,
dude. All right. Literally in 1080p. All right. I would suggest
this. I would suggest I would suggest getting you Prawn. Listen,
I I know I know you're I know you're drunk, and but like listen,
the grope thing is a lot. Get the [__] out of here,
man. No, not not you. This this chatter that you're doing
Prawn, I'm here. You You have a hotel, Prawn. You should have
my phone. I can't be driving out here like this. Yeah, don't
drive. Just find Prawn, and go with Prawn. Can you keep this
Can you keep this here overnight? Rico was innocent. He doesn't
have the mental bandwidth to hurt anyone. Prawn is behind all
of this, using Rico like a scapegoat. So, Prawn can come to the
rescue I think I think Rico is staying with
Rico is saying you sent the clips. He sent you the recording.
I think he should be the one to say Find Prawn. Where's Where's
Prawn at? Prawn Prawn just called me asking to see who's staying
with him. There's two beds. He said that he would sleep with
you and if I wanted to sleep with you as long as you're not going
to drive. Get so Prawn to pull up over here. Are you going to
stay Are you going to stay at the casa with me? Are we streaming
more?
No, tonight. What if we're not? What if we're not? I just I want
a bed. I want a bed and if I can choose between Prawn and then
he's going to be there. What if I wake up and he's on top of
me groping me? Yeah, I don't See, no, this is like this is like
No, but this is like Okay, that doesn't mean that like That No,
that's my point too. Like I pulled over here though. Yeah, but
you were like You touched both of those girls, bro. I would rather
stay with Prawn. Why don't you stay, too? Would that make you
feel safe? Who said? Would that actually make you feel safe?
She's trying to make content. [__] you're the one
who's trying to people and make it content. said I'm sorry. So,
are you staying with Prawn? Said I'm sorry. Uh I guess I can.
Okay, let's go. But I was going to say my boy Nathan Rico Gotti,
do not drive. Prawn has multiple white women. You can go rope
them. go to my boys first and like grab myself Merky is tight.
Yeah, well, then your boys your boyfriend's going to want to
talk you into staying there. No, I'll be fine with it. Okay.
Do not touch me. Don't look at me. Don't I'm not going to touch
you. Don't actually You seriously you you shouldn't touch her,
okay? You can come with us. Are you going to come? Is your Is
your car okay staying here said he only gropes snow bunnies.
Until 3:00 a.m.? Prawn, leave him alone. Okay, take a picture.
Take a picture. lady boys for you if you want that. No, take
a picture of it and we'll go come back before we leave. me the
address and I'll pull up, bro. Prawn needs to get Rico alone
in his room so they can Prawn is like his Like you're
really drunk right now, so don't My fiance? Watch Rico. Don't
look at Merky.
are you You staying somewhere else as Do you think she's going
to Do you think Merky's going to make you sleep in the same bed?
Should be style. I ain't going I ain't going to touch Merky with
a 10-ft pole, dog. I'm not going to touch her. Just don't drive,
bro. Wait, how about I drive? I'm sober. You want to drive me
to the motel? I can drive. All right, good. Okay, let me ask.
Okay, I'm going to drive his car and I'm going to get to the
hotel.
I'll go with you. So, you're saying you're going with me? So,
you don't want to drive us all the way there? Wait, no. Well,
I was going to go to pick up Nathan's place and then you staying
there? Well, then I got to go get my guitar
No, I was going to get my stuff again. your pants, load up. All
right, and then you drop us off at the hotel. Then we all go
to the hotel. All right. They'll go with you. Like, what are
you doing? Does that not make sense? Yeah, that does make sense.
I just put all my stuff in here, so now I have to take it back
out. Thank you. I appreciate you. You want to hang out at the
hotel with us? We can hang out in the lobby or something. Well,
just shut it in his bro. What? That's so disrespectful, bro.
You're Bruce, right? Yeah, I want to go to Nathan's place and
grab my stuff. No, just go grab your stuff. Well, I was going
to stay there, but Now you're going to Yeah, now cuz yeah, cuz
cuz Rico makes her uncomfortable, so I got to And and you need
Spidey there, right? Uh well, we I can drive his car. Or or I
mean Yeah, I can drive Yeah, cuz I'm such a good driver, and
so You're sober now, right? I'm sober.
He only cares about his theater and his dumb guitar. You guys
are All right, I'll see you tomorrow. Okay. It was nice meeting
you. Let me get a hug or something. Please don't drive drunk
with no Dude, I'm not drunk, bro. Like, at all. I'm just like
maybe have a concussion. Thank you. It was nice meeting you.
Thank you. You clutched up so hard. You saved my ass. Dude. Yeah,
dude. I got you. You and that bartender guy like saved my I was
instantly I was out here. I thought you went to the bus stop.
Uh I was looking for like anywhere to go. I put like I luckily
found some guy that was like super chill and like I'm like dial
up like join my Discord like talk to bro through and it was so
good. It was so good. But okay, I'll see you tomorrow. I'll I'll
message you. You got me on Discord, right? What is this guy's
D G G? me and then we'll start from there. You mind helping me
out real quick? I'm going to throw this back in his car. Yeah,
guitar would 100% work on Voldemort. Or all it never been more
Because my Nathan was going to fix the string. I fixed it. Thank
you. Arigato.
Yeah, I'm going to throw this under your
W vagina. Thank you.
Okay, all right. Thank you so much again. I really do appreciate
it.
I'll be safe. I'll be safe. I'll be safe. Okay, all right. Jesus
Louise. What a day, dude. What is Is you sure? Yeah. I can't
even say his name
You got to tell already? Oh, yeah, thank you. Muchas gracias.
Thank you. Yeah, I do not feel that bad. I'm never leaving my
house again after this weekend. This is definitely a some Whose fault
is it? Darius' fault, bro. No, you're the groper. Be quiet. You're
He can kick out a bunch. He's He's pretty active. He's always
triggering All right, we're just going to do with my eye like
this. I swear, guys, he turned himself into a
Bro, get the [__] out of my chat, bro. You can't
call me a pearl, you dog.
Get out of my chat, man. [__] I don't want to I don't
want to [__] with them day ones, bro. Rico gang.
Oh, Rico gang, you mean Rico gang, baby. Works on the black eye
and decided that he'll be her protector.
Wait, bro. We're going to blow up the whole thing. The only girls
that They don't even know about it. I'll see you soon. They don't
want to know, brother. I'm saying, get the [__] out
of my chat, you hating on on me, baby.
Oh god.
Obama. Obama. Mang, I know I understand, bro. There's a whole
situation going on where like Listen, mang, I understand, bro.
There's a whole situation going on. Rico gang. Rico gang. That's
what I'm trying to say, bro. Rico gang. Rico gang. Shut up the
whole gang.
Yeah, I can't believe he had 100 viewers at one point. Yo, wait.
You got like the whole Illuminati Freemason black eye. You're
in there, dude. What the [__] is that? You You never
You You don't know what Fifth gang. Fifth gang. Rico, I can't
even have you on camera, bro. Stop.
Group gang. Group gang. Group gang.
I don't know what you're talking number one, baby. We take it
back to Wait, you have the keys. I did it. Oh, good. Yo, you're
in there. Let's go get some breakfast. You just got jumped in.
All right, just get get it back. You're about to You're about
to blow up. I was I listen, bro, I'm doing you a favor. I'm doing
you a favor. I can't be part of Stream Now cuz all this happened
now. That'd be a black eye for you, bro. Rico number I I I pressed
up I pressed up I pressed up You not a I pressed up You a bad
luck I was like, "Hey, hey, won't be seen." No, why are you hitting
my camera? I said, "Stop." I said, "Stop." I said, "Respectfully,
stop." Respectfully, Cuz they want to see it. Respect No, they
don't, bro. Dude, do you want to see Rico Gotti on camera? Type
one if you want to see Rico Gotti on camera. Type two if you
don't. Nah, they they see me looking. They're not going to type
two, though. I ain't going to back you up no more. Don't back
me up, bro. Yes. This guy is going to be like this. I ain't backing
up How can I survive being in the same They could tell them in
the chat that I How come you didn't back up Darius? How come
you won't back up Darius? Don't chill during the car ride. All
right, it's going
I will help this out, bro. No, but you're here. Hey, man, bro,
I'll help this out, bro. I pressed up to you, bro, dog. I really
not have You had six people jump you and I was there, dog. You
going to say this is a new clip, there for you, dog. Dude, stop.
You got I I'm not joking. You got to chill. You like getting
You like getting aggressive towards me. But I was there. It's
nothing but haters in the chat, Let Darius focus while he drives.
Just chill until you get there. I am crazy world Darius got a
worse eye than Tyler Owens' brother right now.
Zips been here. It's on site, Rico. Be It's not on site, bro,
cuz all these streamers, they ain't about that life like me,
baby.
Why did you Okay, so the girls are visibly moving away from you
and you're
like physically closer over it. You know what I mean? Why Why
you got to show the [__] first?
So they had to move you, bro. You look musty, bro.
They got your mans. My girl
My girl
You know I hate you guys so much.
Come on, it's so bad pervy. I'm I'm a pervy if you I try to make
some content, dude. Come on, bro. They got pervy tech. Where
did I pervy tech girl, dude? Hey, pervy guy over there. Hey,
dude. Darius shouldn't be driving and get there you can all talk
about it. You don't Do not say anything. Bond is so [__]
fine. Oh my god. He's fine. Yo. You're very similar to my ex.
Sam Bond is hot. He didn't do anything I don't know if I had
nothing to do with it, but I saw the clip of Sam Bond and I'm
like, "Oh my god." He's so [__] fine. He's tall,
he's lanky. Oh my god. Sorry. Anyway, back to how Rico my bad.
You want to pass? No one asked for Listen, bro. If the best thing
you can do is take accountability, bro. I'm not I already said
I'm sorry. No, it's all good. It's all good. What else do y'all
want from me? I'm not I'm not your daddy, so I'm not going to
tell you what to I said I'm sorry to Hondro. He's the number
one person that Mark, if you double dog 22, I will treat you
better than Sam Bond. I'm a skinny gamer boy. to Ice earlier
cuz I was macking on Kimmy. I didn't mean it. Macking? Okay,
Macking on Kimmy? Not macking. But you were macking on Kimmy?
I didn't know it was her though. I was Chill out and have a silent
car ride. You got to get there and sleep the night off. Pot calling
the kettle black. I've never done that I was trying to mack on
the other girl. Macking is you need to find a new word, maybe
like harassing. Okay, uh No, it's got everything right. We should
see if the hotel has like You too, dog. Get off my show, bro.
That's even worse not knowing.
If you're don't ever let me see you, Tell your girlfriend. It's
this man, okay? It doesn't matter who it was that was assaulted.
Yo, turn that radio off. I want you to talk. Let's talk about
Rico's and my Real Zip Zip here. I didn't say that. Rico's a
weirdo. It's nice. Got a ring to it. Zip Zippy here and you'll
get in my Rico got a lot of charges.
Charges are being blown up for the wrong reason. You're the one
who said it was Real Zip Zip here it's on tight Rico on site
Zip Zip. I'm very good. You asked Murk.
Fake Zip Zip here I did say that.
I'm going to watch you.
Rico about to slap Murk. Lol.
Four girls hottie. Bro, four girls Rico is going to kick your
car and leave you stranded. What? Four girls, bro. You shut up.
up and wait until after you get your ass though, like what guy
would do what I did tonight for their act? Just have a chill
car ride. Like it's like it's got to say something, right? No,
it says It's got to say I cared more than her. No, it it's got
to That's crazy though, right?
Like I definitely like if there's like a if there's like a competition
for like biggest simp X, I would Rico, you can [__]
people without consent just like how Shena punched Darius in
the eye.